ich finde es reicht es muss jetzt
aufgehört werden dass klimaaktivisten
verharmlos werden als Klimaschützer und
als klimaaktivisten denn was wir jetzt
in lützerath gesehen haben finde ich es
mehr als nur radikal und da haben sich
eben auch Aktivisten gemein gemacht mit
diesen Extremisten die unsere Polizei
also unsere Gesetzeshüter angegriffen
haben als Faschisten beleidigt haben sie
haben beträgt auf sie geworfen mit Stein
mit Molotow Cocktails ein Polizist vor
Ort meinte zu mir sie haben mit alles
auf die Polizisten geworfen was sie
gefunden haben überhaupt auf dem Boden
und trotzdem verharmlosen Politiker und
Medien seit Jahren und immer noch und
auch während Blitzer Rat als als die
Räumung lief diese klimaaktivisten und
wir haben das gesehen beispielsweise im
WDR dort durfte 50 Minuten lang eine
Pressekonferenz von den lutzerat
Besetzern gezeigt werden total
unkommentiert und eine Sanitäterin die
in wahr Aktivistin ist und Mitglied bei
der Grünen Jugend die durftet dann von
Polizeigewalt reden obwohl sie gar keine
Beweise dazu vorlegt und bis heute auch
nicht vorliegt und und eigentlich fragt
man sich doch ob das alles eine
klimaschow war denn diese Heuchelei ist
doch gewaltig die wir dort erlebt haben
ein eine Geisterstadt die sich
eigentlich zu dieser Protest in einer
Geisterstadt der sich eigentlich
entwickelt hat zu einer reinen selbst
Inszenierung wenn die grüne Aktivistin
Luisa Neubauer plötzlich Fotos und
Videos von ihr macht wie sie ein Buch
liest wenn sie wenn sie davon getragen
wird von den Polizisten mit einem Schild
mehr selbst Inszenierung geht nicht und
wie heuchlerisch ist das eigentlich von
den Grünen politischen BeobachterInnen
aus dem Bundestag ähm die dort
eigentlich das Geschehen beobachten
wofür sie selbst abgestimmt haben und
ich frage mich wirklich wie groß kann
die Heuchelei von grünen Aktivisten und
grün Politiker noch werden
ich möchte sie zunächst mal fangen Sie
Verständnis dafür für junge Menschen die
fürs Klima kämpfen die sich dran kleben
die eigentlich sagen ihr alten ihr müsst
unsere Zukunft verändern nicht nur
Verständnis sondern sogar Bewunderung
das ist sehr gut wenn junge Menschen das
tun aber was nicht gut ist wenn sie
selbst gerecht sind wenn sie glauben
alleine im Besitz der absoluten Wahrheit
zu sein wenn sie ihre Gegner oder ihre
Kritiker mundtot machen und das passiert
sehr oft ist wächst eine Wolke
Generation die sehr intolerant ist gegen
andere Meinungen und das ist genauso
gefährlich wie Klimawandel Frau Schäfer
was befürchten sie steuern wieder in so
einer altspaltung der Gesellschaft rein
brauchen wir ein bisschen mehr
Pragmatismus auch in dieser Debatte ich
wollte gerade noch anschließen also ich
lerne schon auch widersprechen dass wir
nicht sagen können die ganze Generation
wächst jetzt auf in eine Richtung wie
sieht das eben beschrieben haben sondern
das ist jetzt ein Aspekt und dieser
Aspekt wird natürlich sehr gepusht durch
die Medien ist vollkommen klar das ist
ja auch die Aufgabe der Medien aber mehr
Pragmatismus ganz wichtig über alles
gesehen wenn ich von außen schaue ist
Bildung immer wieder Bildungs hatten sie
vorhin auch sehr schön angesprochen das
ist wichtig ist oder auch wie sie jetzt
von historischen kommen dass wir die
Zusammenhänge lernen zu verstehen dass
wir mit der Bildung und das ist
phänomenal möglich heute mit den neuen
Medien ja das sehr viel natürlich wollen
nicht alle zu Hause am Bildschirm lernen
aber wir haben ganz neue Möglichkeiten
überhaupt Informationen
erhalten zu können uns Gedanken machen
zu können austauschen zu können das ist
jetzt ein Anfang wir sind jetzt in einer
unglaublichen markanten total wichtigen
Schwelle wo ist kippt vom
sagen wir so vom niederschwelligen oder
niederträchtigen ja hin zu einem
bewussteren zu einem bewussteren
Gesellschaft wir sind in diesem Übergang
und Übergänge sind immer eben sehr
radikal das was am Sterben ist das alte
bewusst und das ist mir sehr laut ja
aber da muss ich direkt einlegen weil
sie meinten das ist die Aufgabe von
Medien die habe ich Aufgabe von Medien
ist aber kritisch darüber zu berichten
und ich finde ganz viele Medien tun das
nicht und vor allem leider in letzter
Zeit mal wieder der Rundfunk hat das
auch bei Anne Will gesehen eine Talkshow
bei beim bei der ARD wie die Position
besetzt sind das ist dann mehrheitlich
von grünen Position besetzt ja eine
grüne Politikerin zwei grüne Aktivisten
vor allem Luisa Neubauer und kriter
tunberg also da hätte man auch eine eine
davon hätte gereicht und Luisa Neubauer
darf dann halt da auch sitzen und viele
sagen was dann einfach so stehen
gelassen wird und das ist total
unkritisch und das ist nicht die Aufgabe
von den öffentlich-rechtlichen wenn ich
total habe ich jetzt hier nicht sitzen
Frau Thunberg und von Neubauer nicht
aber was würden sie den beiden Frauen
entgegnen würden Sie hier mit unseren
Tisch sitzen also wenn man das
Klimaproblem so hoch aufhängt wie die
das tun und da gibt es gute Gründe was
zu tun oder auch nicht zu tun dass eine
ganze beratete Werte aber wenn man das
tut dann sollte man eigentlich top-down
sich überlegen was sind eigentlich die
wirksamsten Maßnahmen und da finde ich
das so abstrus dass eine letzte
Generation
sich
festklebt mitten im Winter im Beton weil
sie ein Tempolimit und einen neuen
euro-ticket fördern das ist ungefähr so
viel von der ganzen von dem ganzen
großen Kuchen den ich lösen müssen und
als wenn man top down sich das überlegt
im schauen wie groß wie wie kriegt man
auf der Welt die CO2 Emission runter die
kriegen sie in Deutschland runter und
dann gleichzeitig aber und das ist ja
gerade grüne Politik Atomkraftwerke
abzuschalten ich glaube ich darf danach
noch mal was dazu
absurd also wenn sie sich in im
sie festkleben werden statt ein lützi
dann dann würde ich das verstehen aber
so ist es halt irgendwo das verpufft das
verpufft ins Leere ich bin im übrigen
auch da muss ich auch wieder sprechen in
ihrem Sinne fahrschäfer weil ich also
ich habe zwei Töchter in dem Alter die
sozusagen in der wir so
Fridays for future Alter und die haben
halt auch erzählt also das war immer nur
eine kleine Minderheit die sich davon
hat anstecken lassen und es war auch in
der letzten Bundestagswahl so dass die
stärkste
Partei bei den erst Wählern war die FDP
die eben ein sehr sehr positives
Zukunftsbild hat und kein Angst geleitet
ist Zukunftsbild und das macht mir dann
auch ein bisschen Hoffnung das heißt sie
würden würde Greta Thunberg
beispielsweise jetzt hier mit einem
Tisch sitzen sagen habe keine Angst vor
der Zukunft absolut das ist nicht so
dramatisch
also nein die CO2 ist in der Tat ein
wichtiges Thema und das über das muss
man reden aber und wir werden das auch
lösen aber es geht über Technologie und
nicht über Verzicht weil sie können dem
Unternehmer dem Kleinunternehmer in
Bengalen in Vietnam in Ruanda dem können
sie nicht sagen du musst jetzt aber
verzichten sondern der will ja auch zu
uns aufschließen also müssen wir uns
konzentriert und überlegen wie komme ich
dahin dass alle auf dem Wohlstand kommen
aber dass die planetaren Grenzen
trotzdem gewahrt werden und dafür gibt
es drei Ansätze das eine ist
Konzentration also wir brauchen zu viel
Landfläche also müssen uns konzentrieren
und nur Technologien entwickeln die
Flächen konzentriert sind
dann brauchen wir eine eine bessere
Kreislaufwirtschaft weil wir zu viel
Müll in die in die Welt eintragen das
ist eigentlich fast noch größere Problem
als der erste Klimawandel würde ich mal
sagen und das dritte ist wir müssen das
mit höchstem kostenbewusst sein machen
weil wir ansonsten eben die das wir
können es vielleicht im reichen
Deutschland bisschen was erreichen aber
so viel aber die ganze Welt wird uns
nicht folgen und warum machen wir das
weil wir Nahrung Rohstoffe und Energie
aus der Natur brauchen und diese drei
Dinge das können Sie jetzt überlegen
also sozusagen drei mal drei Matrix
überlegen gibt's dafür Technologien mit
denen wir das erreichen kann entweder in
Laboren oder vielleicht sind die schon
fertig entwickelt die also preisgünstig
sind Flächen konzentriert und eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft und möglichen und
natürlich gibt's solche Technologien ich
schreibe gerade einen Artikel drüber das
Ding ich kann leider kein so schönes
Buch präsentieren da aber ich noch dran
aber ich habe nun mal noch einen anderen
Job das ist ein bisschen schwierig aber
es gibt solche Technologien und deswegen
ist es keine Utopie sowas zu erreichen
sondern das wird in diesen nächsten
Jahrzehnten auch passieren
kommen solche Botschaften an und auch du
sagst Lüge und Heuchelei darauf möchte
ich noch mal zurückkommen was sind die
Punkte die du ganz konkret vorwirfst
viele Jugendliche denken sich vielleicht
ist doch toll wir setzen uns für die
Zukunft ein Lüge und Heuchelei an
welchen Punkten ist ja das man jetzt
sagt an lützerat würde jetzt alles
dieses Klima genesen also das ist ja ich
weiß ja nicht also dass die
Wissenschaftler sich uneins wie weit
lutzerat wirklich dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel
erreichen könnte wie man sich daran
nähert viele Wissenschaftler sagen ja
jetzt schon man kann das erstmal auch
gar nicht erreichen was man sich gesetzt
hat also das ist ja schon mal so eine
Art Lügen und natürlich ist es auch
Heuchelei was die grünen Politiker und
da betreiben zuerst stimmen die im
Bundestag ab von den braunen Kohle aus
Musik und damit letzte Rad also dieser
Deal halt das ist dafür eine Draht das
Dorf geopfert wird und man früher
aussteigt dafür die stimmt dafür ab und
dann setzen Sie sich wahrscheinlich ins
Auto und fahren dahin beobachten das und
schreiben noch dass sie auf Twitter dass
sie sich davon in fremden von dieser
lützeraträumung und man müsste das doch
jetzt stoppen noch also das ist total
die Heuchelei ist mein erster für
abstimmt und ganz ehrlich die Grünen
sind sowieso die größte räucherlöschere
Politik von der ganzen Ampel weil wenn
sie wirklich Klimaschutz wollen dann
hätten sie ja wieder die AKWs auch ja
zurückholen können quasi also dass wir
aus den Ausstieg der Peter ist gleich
zustimmen da können wir aber gleich ja
2016 haben die Grünen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die die Verlängerung
der Braunkohle Nutzung damit begründet
das wäre den Atomausstieg haben also die
Grünen waren eigentlich immer eine Kohle
Partei und das vergisst man manchmal